speaking of mental break uh let's let's
go on to my first one which was uh the
one that has an ugly boss in it
because uh I definitely had a [__]
mental breakdown after I watched this
one I had a mental breakdown on two
separate occasions yeah challenge again
so my name yes
um and trust me uh whether I like it or
not when you're when you're perusing
through the the wide world Cesspool of
hentai you will come across ugly bosses
whether you like it or not yes and uh
and Saul was like all right what's the
worst one and so I went with uh an
hentai called
um
which is in Japanese it means even still
I love my wife
this this
isn't pretty confusing because when you
recommended it there are actually like
two two of these right yes this this is
actually this is
one with multiple episodes and then
there's a second season
yeah with different characters
to watch one but I actually watched both
as well oh really and I regret it yeah
so so I recommend I recommend the second
one the second season because uh in the
second episode the second season second
season yeah
um because it has an ugly bastard which
I'm sure if you've been on any Twitter
before you've definitely seen the ugly
bastard in this yeah
yeah yeah I had that's that's the that's
what I mean when I said I had two
different types of mental yeah one
because the show was just goddamn
horrible and two because I was like oh
my God this is where this guy comes from
I've seen this image of this
[__] so many times this is the
one
um so basically also the other mental
breakdown I had was just how convoluted
the plot dude what I I had man it's like
you know when you read a book and you
read a line you're like I gotta take
that in again yeah I did that so many
times and I was so confused so so if I
can remember correctly there is a a
husband and a wife all right I mean are
they and they already and their teacher
yeah that's a student or what no no no
no so oh my God so there was a husband
and a wife the wife is a teacher at a
college yeah right and the college
teacher the wife is in cahoots with one
of her students who looks exactly like
her husband but but her husband also
looks like a kid as well but her husband
also looks like a kid like it's so
confusing yeah it's like a younger
version of her husband yeah but
basically that she's in she's so while
like he's on a [__] business triple
no no she goes to work in a different
School far away oh yeah that's right
yeah so yeah so the life goes to work
far away at the school but they're still
mad but they're still married yeah but
because she's far away she sees this
student that looks exactly like her
husband and goes like you know I feel a
bit lonely at work because we're always
so literally like one minute in one
minute one minute in yeah and the guys
and the student is like don't worry
teach I I got you bro yeah and then they
start and basically the husband the
husband gets NTR yeah and then there's
this weird like B plot when it goes to
the husband's perspective yeah yeah
there's this other girl who's introduced
and she's kind of friendly with him yeah
uh and that doesn't really go anywhere
for a while until she drugs him yeah at
the end of the day episode she drugs him
and then it cuts but yeah but like
that's right at the end yeah like
obviously but basically so basically the
wife and the and the teacher having and
the student are having this like very
secret intimate relationship and the
owner of the apartment who is the ugly
bastard in question manages to snap a
picture of them kissing right and
basically leave the building yeah and
basically uses that as blackmail to be
like Hey so uh I saw you having sexual
relations with this student you don't
want the teacher you don't want the
school to find out right you know what
you got to do I feel like people are
having an easier time following the plot
of inception right now there are like so
many different things
and man is this guy the ugliest of ugly
okay
I am pretty sure I am pretty sure okay
that this hentai was made in order to
limit test boners okay it's it's because
okay here's the thing first five minutes
this is a A plus hentai okay you got a
hot teacher you gotta know you like the
ntring of the the student sorry you like
the NTR part with the student the answer
like at this point the husband hasn't
been introduced right well we we I guess
we had a little bit of the husband a
tiny bit no we don't we don't really get
not enough to care about no no we don't
care okay okay you know that's that's
it's it's like a little bit of light
cheating you know it's it's it's it's
different from NTR all right it's not
full it's it's like not full on NTR
evaluation is good it has no right the
animation is good it looks [__]
incredible the teacher is like an st
dude I watched this [__] in 1080P yeah I
was like I almost wished it didn't exist
yeah the teacher is is great yeah yeah
talks and does things I I was like this
this is this is this is great and then
you get the shot of the ugly bastard and
I swear this shot of the ugly boss I
know the one you're talking about yeah
yeah yeah it's vile it's it's the sh
it's the full body shot of the ugly
bastard and I swear to God I could hear
Dark Soul music when like the shot comes
on is this so correct this man is the
final boss of ugly bastards the [__]
health
yeah he takes up the whole frame yeah
yeah because like I remember like I've
I've seen my fair share of ugly bastards
but the first time I watched this my jaw
dropped to the floor it was like that
that that's who that's who they're
introduced that's that's a person yeah
that's a real person that ain't a person
okay yeah I mean some of these shots
some of these shots like were framed and
I swear to God she was [__] she was like
[__] a Titan oh okay that was my
nitpick with like the first like NTR
scene with the ugly bastard I got more
than nitpicks there's this there's
different shots of like you know them
[__] doing whatever and they can't
stay consistent with the size of this
dude because there's one shot where he
looks like 12 feet tall and then there's
another one where he looks like you know
the Hunchback guy from 300 like he kind
of looks like that guy and I'm like why
are you like all right what's happening
I had to skip through the sex scene I
couldn't watch it it was it was so gross
no you needed to watch the sex scene to
feel the pain no I didn't want I
couldn't do it I couldn't do it yeah it
was it was gross it was bad like you
know in some scenes of Attack on Titan
where there's like a really really small
Titan with a really big head
now like you might imagine Like a Porn
version of that and that's what this
anime was that was just what the sex
scenes was like this man this man is
literally the embodiment of pot of greed
you know you he has a pot of green face
he has a pot of greed face man and then
like they do it and then I guess the
student comes back and then there's the
teacher's like well the Janet is like
the ugly bastard guy's like well join in
and the kid's like ah okay I'm gonna
join it and it's like what the [__]
yeah I didn't understand that conclusion
that was so weird like like this student
would watch this and be like all right
okay if
you insist it's just like it's just
disgusting like everything was
disgusting yeah in episode two got like
10 times more disgusting episode two was
just weird because I I don't know why
they tried adding in subplots yeah yeah
they added like a b plot and a c plot so
and I'm like I'm still confused from the
first episode because I was trying to
treat like I in my in my mind uh to try
to cope with like what like the
atrocities that was like I was viewing
on screen Geneva Convention somehow I
don't know which one but they broke
something yeah I was I was just trying
to keep back uh keep track of uh so how
many people are getting into yard right
now yeah everyone was getting into yeah
yeah yeah it was just like nobody was
like why don't you all just just just
call it a day no more relationships no
one is allowed because this clearly
isn't working in this universe yeah so
originally it's the husband I guess NTR
because the because the teacher is uh is
finds a student who the student is also
in love with the teacher right so at the
beginning it's the husband getting into
yards but then it's the student and the
husband getting into yard because we
find the ugly bastard but then the
husband finds a yandere who drugs him
and so the husband starts having sex
with the yandere so it's the teacher
getting into you hold up hold up he
doesn't he is very much not doing it
voluntarily she drugged him ties him up
and then she makes him watch a video of
her husband
being destroyed by a dude and then he's
just like drugged out of his mind being
taken advantage of yeah they included
this like they included this weird B
plot which I didn't understand which is
like while the husband is getting into
eyed by this yandere yeah and they play
the video of the wife explaining like
the reason why she's willingly getting
into yard is because like the husband is
in like a bunch of debt or whatever and
then it turns out the ugly boss there's
like some kind of young and he's
involved in some kind of like yeah
when he was cigar and the gold teeth I'm
like
where the [__] did this come why are you
doing a janitorial which I felt like for
some reason the first one was wildly
popular in Japan yeah and they were like
bro we need a sequel he's like bro that
was not supposed
and then they're like all right well
let's make something yeah and then they
made this [__] yeah it's honestly this
was like this was terrible it was bad
like I cannot recommend to not watch
this enough this is so gross so vile I
mean like like just just awful we can
all agree it's the ugliest boss of we've
all seen it is the ugliest boss okay and
I've I've done my job there is the
reason why this guy has become a meme
everywhere if when you search the term
ugly bastard his face will show up
because I would like to see if we can
find an ugly boss uglier bastard than
this because I think after that you're
just in like like isekai Goblin
territory like this I had this uh weird
memory where um I actually realized I
watched this the second one this only
the second episode I've watched it
before okay right maybe watch the first
thing you just like no it was like
trauma and you just blanked it from your
memory I definitely haven't because I
remember I'd watch the second episode
thinking it was like the first episode
of something and I was really confused
yeah um and I think it put me off hentai
for like like
because I was like I was like when they
got to the like the twist of like he'd
been this yandere been doing the thing
to him for so long that he just now is
not even of the sane of mind and he
thinks this woman who is doing the thing
to him is his wife and it was just like
what is this yeah yeah it made me feel
like oh yeah this the NSA is watching me
and they're gonna judge me for this
what what pisses me off about this all
right what pissing me off especially
about this is that
it looks really [__] good like they
this is like for some reason for some
reason queen bee didn't pick this show
up yeah I think I think the scariest
thing about the show is knowing it was
like successful and it was popular
that's that's concerning dude I watched
this [__] in 1080P and I was just like
[__] yeah why did this 1080p version why
do they go so hard why do they have to
they could they could have kept it at 7
20 or 480 like all these other great
series but no this one we needed to see
an Ultra HD it's just like I I you
there's some things you watch
uh some some hentai you watch that
really make you think like man they're
really okay with them showing this but
we can't show a dick like we can we can
we can show this but I but you can't
show an uncensored penis yeah that's
where you draw the line but this is all
fair game all good oh so I was just
looking at my notes and that reminded me
of just like there is so you guys
obviously skipped the ugly bastard sex
scene
you know like I scrubbed with the mouse
thing and stopped any dialogue I know
exactly what was disgusting is aside
from the whole [__] head Titan thing
they gave him so much detail so much
there is this there is there's one
close-up shot that is like I I think I'm
going to have to go to like talk therapy
on this because this is one close-up
shot of his nipple and it is it is in so
much disgusting detail dude there's like
warts on that [__] and like even noticed
there's like one tiny nipple hair on it
and I'm like bro you did not you could
you could have just erased that one I'm
concerned about who this appeals to yeah
I'm concerned about who saw this and
thought finally a show for me like
that's concerning
you must have been uh clearly yeah it's
just like some animator make the
conscious decision to be like we can
make this worse we can make we can put
more detail on this dude I'm just I'm
just imagining the animator just hearing
it from the producer being like you want
me to draw what
I have to draw this and color it in and
animate yeah you know how like people
are like man I I don't care how people
can want to have sex sometimes I'm like
well [__] after watching this I don't
ever want to have sex ever again yeah
yeah there was one thing that did make
me laugh though at the end where it was
it was uh this at the end of episode one
where we it was the yandere right that
the husband was talking to yeah but the
the it was the husband and the Andre at
a bar
uh and the husband was like I think my
wife's like cheating on me I think I
think she's having an affair and the
girl just goes ah cheer up have a drink
that's very Japanese yeah
literally sure good night yeah drink
your sorrows away bro don't worry about
it it's like just just don't be sad it's
just simple just get over it it was it
was that image of like tap and like the
like the scissors and the scissors yeah
this is trying to cut it it's just like
just don't be sad it's easy to go
outside
um so yeah this uh I don't recommend you
watch this island but in fact I
recommend that someone invents a time
machine and goes back in time yeah and
uh prevents this anime from ever being
made I wish I still lived in a in an
ignorant world or full of bliss when I
know you guys I wouldn't I wouldn't
[__] have watched this if I never met
you guys like ever like I would never
have watched that ever I want to go back
in time where I'm like I can just look
at the image of the ugly boss and being
funny image yeah without knowing the
context behind it yeah God damn it